with the delicate tread of the acrobat
she once was Daria moves through the
ruins of her home
the fashionable townhouse near butcher
outside Kiev was the result of years of
hard work as an international circus
performer its loss along with all her
belongings continues to overwhelm
when you lost Everson
you just you don't have a
words
normal words
it's
it's just you don't want to actually you
don't see the sunsense for life
Daria now lives here in a polish-built
container Village a short distance away
and she's decided to share her story
with researchers from the Museum of
Civilian voices
an online resource the museum records
the experiences of ukrainians after
Russia's first Invasion and the
annexation of Crimea in 2014. it
contains more than 66 000 testimonies
as much as it is about preserving the
wartime accounts of Ukrainian civilians
this project is also about therapy and
healing it's about giving every person
who wants it the opportunity to speak
and be heard
people line up to take part
Valentina speaks emotionally not about
her own loss but the pain she feels for
the whole society it's a kind of
Nationwide mobile therapy couch offering
brief moments in the anonymity of war
that Mark each experience as personal
and important
you know I felt relief because I was
able to say what was in my soul what I
probably haven't properly processed yet
we need this help we really need it it's
so hard for us to explain what we've
experienced and what we've lost in one
moment what you invested everything in
it's gone and you have nothing left it
leaves you empty inside
Valentina ends with a poem she wrote
to have life in peace it's called where
everyone is familiar and all share a
love of the motherland
there is Comfort too in knowing that
each individual account of loss is
shared by so many
Jonah Hull Al Jazeera butcher
and you can watch more of those powerful
testimonials by more than 66 000
ukrainians mentioned in Jonah Hall's
report a civil voicesmuseum.org